[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin Millar won a World Series uh title
with the 2004 Red Sox he works for the
MLB Network and postseason begins today
you can watch Kevin on MLB network
coverage including intentional talk
throughout the playoffs here and uh you
can get the entire schedule mlb.com
postseason how you doing how you doing
Kevin Danny I miss you I mean I need you
to pick up your energy level right now
you sound sad I need you to say this is
mala and that's me
Kevin Malone joining us uh on the
program all right uh Harold Reynolds was
with us yesterday and he says he has
concern about the Dodgers pitching staff
that's his only concern how big a
concern is that for you
I you know I I'm not going to tell you
there's a concern at all for the Dodgers
they won 111 games uh this this team has
been great I know that you know the
World Series they only have one I have a
Dodger fan in the car right now with me
but listen the bottom line is this we
could nitpick every team there's not a
perfect club uh the only concern I have
they're a match-up based Club at times
you know it's like they have two
different lineups and I know that Dr and
I used to play together and shower
together like you know for many many
many many months uh as he pinched ran
for me in molasses but the point of this
is it would have been tough for me to
play in this type of generation with all
of these matchups lefties and righties
and we've seen guys in the postseason
play trainings in their righty would
come in then put in Max Muncie that's
the only concern I have is that in this
playoff season I think the game is fast
and ready and you kind of need to know
who your dudes are
your Dark Horse team or teams
are who
Guardians and I think game one Shane
wins that game and you're saying Shane
they're both named Shane exactly but I
think the Guardians are playing really
good baseball right now I think they're
the second best records of September 1st
they're a sneaky Club because they make
contact and what they do is they don't
strike out they play defense it's a
unique way because right now we're
seeing High strikeouts and big home runs
and all that stuff the Guardians they
kind of play Old School baseball
well I wonder if that's coming back if
if the commissioner you know with the
baseball bought Rawlings so they can do
whatever they want to with the baseballs
but it feels like from David Cohn saying
hey what judge did is remarkable even
more so because the ball is not as
Lively so is baseball doing its best to
have you put the ball in play just
because you can't just swing for home
runs now because you're not going to be
hitting them as as often as you think or
the analytics would not you know kind of
bear that out yeah I just think that
like the game this year I think was
better I think to get you know the
playoff situation is better but I just
know that one thing I just I
I the high strikeouts and the shifts and
everything going crazy back and forth
that's kind of taking it away because I
was doing the wrestling game and I saw
divers up and I'm sitting there in
Fenway Park and I see four outfielders
first time I saw that in person it
looked weird and to me were the only
sport before this you know this this
rule change that didn't have rules you
have the three-point key I mean you have
the you know the key in the NBA you have
you can't line up so many guys in NFL
but we're the only we're the only key
are T you know League that had no rules
now we have a little normalcy again you
know and so when you watch a team like
the Indians use an example like I I like
the way they play you have the Francona
Factor The Experience Factor but at the
end of the day it is a nice refreshing
way to see contact and stolen bases and
baseball
if I said you could have Aaron judge
from now on
or shohei Otani from here on out
what a great question and this is why I
love you because you asked amazing
questions I would take ohtani because
you have two players I'm sorry it's a
weird weird deal judges my MVP
but how do you how do you discount what
otani's done because it's almost like
you got to pay two players when he got
the one year 30 million dollar
arbitration I'm like all right that's
cool that's for the three Hole by the
way who steals 30 bags hits 30 home runs
hits in the middle of the lineup and the
guy that what struck out 200 plus now
that's another 30 million so really it's
a one year 60. it's a unique thing I
think he's an he's another level because
he is the MVP it doesn't make sense but
then what judge does
it's the best year that we've ever seen
you know opinion based okay but if you
were shoheheotani's agent yeah would you
after this season
would you stay with the angels
or get him someplace else where he's
actually playing in meaningful games
being on a national stage
yeah that and that's a question that you
and I because you and I are his agent we
go behind the scenes are you comfortable
here we know the flight to Japan is a
lot closer obviously the big stage in
New York yeah in Boston and you know do
you go down the road to the Dodgers the
Angels got to get better end of story
they have to get better for me to stay
there long term and we can sit and talk
about all day long they spent money
Artie Moreno you know has done a great
job of hearing some checkbooks they
haven't done a great job of spending at
the right place but we've been hearing
this for 10 years yeah Mike Trout's a
decade in I know I know so if I'm shohei
and I want to win
and on a big stick then I leave if he's
comfortable there though not everybody's
makeup is east coast wise and you know
that yeah we can sit here and say oh
yeah can you play New York you can't
play in Boston until one bad month and
then they bury you and now where are you
at mentally but I also wonder about that
with the Giants the Giants are a
faceless franchise if you could get
judged to come back home or maybe show
hey uttani playing in San Francisco I
also wonder about the Red Sox the Red
Sox almost are giving the impression
they're a smaller Market team now at
least they're spending do they go all in
on Aaron judge or do they make the
Yankees pay top dollar can you imagine
Aaron judge in Fenway
yeah no I you could imagine Aaron judge
anywhere and I will say this about Aaron
judge and you and you know you've done a
lot of athletes and great dudes but
watching this guy at six seven three
hundred pounds six seven two ninety Run
play center field goes into the spring
training says no to 200 million no thank
you in a pleasant way it wasn't a big
old dispute and I hate everybody it was
a pleasant way and then bets on himself
and then puts this year together with
the surroundings around him that he he
he's the only guy like Rizzo and these
guys listen I'm not just you know taking
anything away from him I mean 30 plus
home runs but Aaron judge was the only
guy in that lineup and led in every
offensive category but if you're the Red
Sox do you go all in on Aaron judge
well then I got I got Devers and I got
Xander over there so what do you do
Danny I don't have 1.5 billion dollars
so I got to make that decision on my
left side of my infield Devers is a
player so I probably don't go all in on
Aaron judge okay because when you go all
in on Aaron judge and one position
player does that what okay if you're the
Giants if you're the Giants do you go
all in on Aaron judge
I don't think they're there yet and I'd
say no okay all right uh got one other
one for you whose career
Albert pujolses
Ken Griffey Jr
wow griffy because the marketing aspect
he's Rich Forever period in a story but
I do want to get one more point across
and I'm sorry for the Broncos loss last
night that was a that was a tough game
and I know
and you know what it's not an
organizational it's not a quarterback
you just need to get it together because
that was a hard one to watch maybe they
need to Cowboy Up
maybe we need some Cowboy Up me and you
sideline passes I think I think we need
to have them do shots before uh you know
they play Play It Again did you guys
only do one shot each before you went
out and played in the playoffs that year
yeah let's get in trouble one more time
no you're not getting in trouble but but
so you drank whiskey was it Whiskey yeah
okay yeah Jack Daniels remember we were
down three it was raining Jack Daniels
we have symbolic toast yep a shot boom
one well obviously you win we're
superstitious so we did it eight eight
times in a row did Terry Francona do a
shot with you
just Pippin to Jordan from downtown
so your manager did shots with you not
symbolic toast Danny symbolic toast we
were just Cowboy Up okay here's the last
thing Marvin he's got a Blue Jays hat on
says it's one of the top five baseball
logos
I like it I think yes top five okay it's
the loudest playoff playoff place you're
gonna play in in these I don't care
about that I'm talking about the logo
the Hat the white the blue with the with
with the blue jay I'm in yeah top five
for sure
okay the best logo is who
la
uder blue and it's classy
yeah LA Dodger blue I'm sorry but it's
time for a Dodger baseball
have you been drinking this morning
no I'm at Driftwood the discovery
property out in Austin Texas we just
pulled up it's a beautiful course yeah
it's the discovery property so I'll let
you know how I do okay
Todd's got my cell phone you don't for
some reason so shoot me a text I'll let
you know yeah I you know I'd like to
have that separation you know I don't I
don't want you got rich
when you weren't Rich you didn't have
that separation I cared about you when
you were doing shots when you were with
the Red Sox after that not as much
as much and now I'm white I look like
this last year you don't want to look
like farv at all right now I you don't
want to don't know Santa Claus Santa
Claus guys I take it back well you're
not frosting your hair anymore
Danny I'm old now my back I blew out my
hamstring going to bed like what what
hey okay
how do you blow out your hamstring going
to bed I don't know
I go go potty and I can't walk I guess I
pulled something and then breathe I have
no idea all right be careful out there
okay miss you Danny great to talk to you
as always yeah yeah that's Kevin Millar
MLB network analyst and that should make
you feel better Kevin Millar is with you
absolutely yeah I love that guy won a
World Series a title with the Red Sox 04
MLB network uh before and after all the
games that's the place to go are good
friends there and also uh he does
intentional talk throughout the playoffs
there